[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
spécialité le magazine est consacrée
comme vous le savez à l'actualité
sportive dans le département à ces
parties a pour le sommaire rugby nous
ferons le bilan de la saison du club
yvelinois coup de projecteur aujourd'hui
sur plaisir qui évolué en fédérale 2 de
ski rugby et versailles pensionnaire de
division honneur et sur montigny le
bretonneux qui jouait cette année en
promotion honneur les détails dans ce
magazine handball plaisir a réussi une
brillante saison dans le championnat de
nationale 3 pour leur première année
dans cette division les plaisirs aux en
terminer deuxièmes ils ont également
raté de justesse l'accession en
nationale 2 en s'inclinant en barrages
nous avons retracé à leur parcours
fitness cani baradji originaire de
voisins-le-bretonneux a été élue miss
france 2010 8,7 secondes sportive de 29
ans pratique la musculation deux à trois
fois par semaine en scène des condos
zumba nous la recevrons dans ce set 8
sport le bilan de la saison 2017-2018
c'est maintenant sur tv 68
[Musique]
on commence cette émission par du rugby
les clubs y vino avec une saison
2017-2018 contrastée entre joie suspense
et désillusions les supporteurs ne se
sont pas ennuyés cette année coup de
projecteur sur montigny le bretonneux
plaisir versailles le sky rugby en ce
reportage un montage deux axes et les
jeannin les clubs de rugby vinoy sont
passés par toutes les émotions cette
saison le sky rugby fêter sa remontée en
honneur après trois ans d'absence pour
le retour les saint-quentinois ont lutté
jusqu'à la fin du championnat pour
s'assurer le maintien il termine
finalement la sixième place du
classement
il faut pas rajouter une seule chose il
faut toujours rajouter plein de petites
choses pour que ça se passe bien
là faut être meilleur a physiquement
meilleur quelques joueurs qui viennent
un peu plus un peu plus chanceux sur sur
une blessure parce qu'on a bien chargé
cette année en blessure donc donc ça
arrive mais elle reviendra peut-être
moins deux mois de malchance là dessus
et après c'est toujours progresser c'est
à dire que là au match aller on a fait
en a fait trois victoires et et aux
mascottes on a fait 3 victoires + 1 nul
donc ces lieux dans le championnat de
promotion honneur le promu montigny le
bretonneux a également flirté avec la
zone de relégation pendant la première
partie de la saison les y montrent un
réussi à se remobiliser à partir de
janvier pour terminer avec un bilan de
huit victoires pour 10 défaites et une
sixième place au classement
[Musique]
du côté de la fédérale 2 plaisir promu
cette saison restera dans cette division
la saison prochaine les plaisirs ont
officiellement validé leur maintien sur
le terrain de domont début avril
la victoire est sans appel 54 à 7
ce jour là les hommes de sébastien
roncalli compte 15 points d'avancé sur
le premier relégable
arras sportivement et de par le travail
effectué par les joueurs
et tout le staff et les dirigeants voilà
je pense que c'est tout à fait mérité
c'était vraiment très important
prépare vraiment des choses on s'est
projeté sur plusieurs années donc ouais
c'était vraiment important de se
maintenir cette saison
versailles a sans doute été l'équipe qui
a procuré le plus de sensations à ses
supporters après avoir terminé 3e de
division honneur derrière sarcelles et
bagneux et jour de la cité royale ont
réussi à se hisser en quarts de finale
du championnat de france en venant à
bout de l'entente maisons laffitte saint
jean les poissy sur le score de 13 à 3
un parcours historique qui s'est
finalement stoppé en quart de finale du
championnat de france verset s'incline
11 à 0 contre l'un des favoris chalon
sur saône pas de monter pour le club
ce qu'on retiendra de toute façon c'est
que c'est fait c'est une défaite à un
niveau historique pour le club
c'était la première fois que l'équipe
senior du rcv atteignait les quarts de
finale en honneur donc vous avez marqué
voilà cesser les joueurs marchelli
quelle équipe de l'histoire du club avec
leur staff
le championnat terminé les équipes
chinoises ont maintenant plus qu'un
objectif en tête sont renforcés pour
espérer passer un nouveau palier la
saison prochaine on continue à parler de
rugby vous l'avez vu dans leurs
reportages précédents plaisir a réussi à
ce matin dans le championnat de fédérale
2 pour nous parler de cette saison
plaisir oise nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir sur ce plateau le coach
sébastien roncalli bonsoir soit ainsi
que tirer l'amendé le président du club
bonsoir alors est-ce que vous pour vous
c'est un soulagement président de voir
plaisir en fédérale 2 la saison
prochaine
soulagement non parce qu'on l'a vu
progression sur toute la saison entre
les phases aller où c'était très
compliqué après la phase retour les
joueurs ont un peu plus adhérer au
travail des coaches et ça s'est vu au
niveau du pays match le nombre de
victoires et supérieures sont à la phase
retour
non je dirais qu après effectivement il
y avait deux clubs qui était quand même
bien moins armés que nous et on les a
retrouvés derrière
sachant qu'on a finalement fini 8e du
fait de deux
déclassement de deux équipes financières
donc c'était prévisible selon le
président est selon le coach est ce que
c'était prévisible
ces matières le bas c'était l'objectif
qu'on a atteint après oui effectivement
en tout cas on avait des objectifs
précis par rapport à certaines équipes
lyon savait que si on battait ces deux
équipes là sur l'aller-retour on est
assuré du maintien et ça s'est joué
notamment avec eux mais on a réussi
quand même à faire des très bons
résultats face aux autres équipes aussi
c'est une récompense pour les joueurs ah
oui je pense oui c'était très important
où ce qui est beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts de fait et c'est un palier à
franchir et c'est très très important et
c'est une belle récompense pour les
joueurs c'est une récompense également
pour les supporters ils sont nombreux à
chaque match à vous soutenir
ils ont encore été nombreux tout au long
de la saison effectivement on a une
belle ambiance
même les phases finales les led avance
vraiment donné mille cinq cents
personnes c'est bien donc là on est à
500 600 personnes depuis dimanche aux
moyens coach est ce qu'à un moment donné
vous avez envisagé une descente ou pas
du tout non à aucun moment quand même en
début de saison n'ont à aucun moment et
même en milieu de saison on s'est mis un
deuxième objectif par rapport à notre
équipe b qui était de qualifier cette
équipe parce que ben on a un niveau qui
a est très homogène sur nos seniors donc
n'ont droit à aucun moment et de doute
là dessus
président vous avez connu la descente il
ya trois ans est ce que cette année la
saison était complètement différente
est-ce que vous pensez que peut-être les
joueurs ont appris leur erreur j'irai
qu'il ya trois ans on avait aussi une
poule plus tard encore supérieur je
pense que depuis on n'a vu que au moins
quatre équipes c'est pas cinq sont déjà
en fédérale une quoi donc c'était
vraiment un gros challenge et il ya
trois ans était passé à deux doigts quoi
c'est une victoire de plus et le reste
est mais ce qui est à noter c'est que
les joueurs adhèrent de plus en plus
dans son des deux groupes sur la
la suite de la saison passée ont
continué le travail non c'est sebastien
galy vous pensez que certains joueurs
ont poussé qui ont connu justement cette
descente ont poussé cette saison pour ne
pas connaître la même chose encore cette
saison bien sûr que celle qu'on soit
allé en france dans le village tout à
fait le capitaine en tête
oui tout à fait il est hors de question
de revivre la même situation
comme l'a dit mon président ça s'est
joué sur le dernier match
il ya trois ans voilà il fallait pas
revivre cette saison là et tous les
joueurs qu'ils avaient vécu voulait
absolument pas le revivre
et d'ailleurs on à rejouer des équipes
qu'ils avaient joué à cette époque là et
qu'on a battu vous êtes appuyé ce rôle
justement dans la saison complètement
oui on a mon capitaine et puis on a
plusieurs joueurs leaders qui sont très
importants effectivement au sein du
groupe on a l'impression justement quand
on voit on voit le classement qui est
vraiment un championnat à deux vitesses
vous pensez que vos joueurs se sont
préparés à ça tout au long la saison
préparé je pense pas nous on a vu que le
le premier match avait été très
compliqué parce qu'on jouait bobigny qui
était descendante lra lui qui tenait
très bien fédéral une donc ça a eu
peut-être l'effet de leur faire un peu
peur à prendre conscience mais derrière
il ya eu du travail qui a permis de
rebondir au monde et les groupes des
matches très intéressants contre
saint-denis gennevilliers à la maison on
passa vraiment deux doigts afin de les
accrocher pourtant décapité déjà dans le
haut du tableau quoi ces bassins ans
cali à l'année prochaine vous attendez
au même championnat que cette année où
un championnat encore plus compliquée
par rapport à la poule qui sont sortis
les pluies sont sortis la semaine
dernière déjà sur la poule on retrouve
cette équipe qu'on a joués cette année
donc voilà on a quatre quatre nouvelles
équipes
donc forcément c'est des équipes qu'on
connaît un peu déjà mal ont donc non je
pense ça va être assez proche encore une
fois président il faudra renforcer
l'effectif oui avec nos moyens mais
j'irai cnous qui on privilégie c'est
vraiment la formation voit que les
jeunes qui montent juniors on a quand
même réussi en venant corpo
régulièrement canton à chaque montée de
2,3 en moyenne donc sur des philippes
club
on a beaucoup de jeunes qui nous
rejoignent également jeu en a une
quinzaine de joueurs et qui viennent
nous rejoindre
s'il n'y a pas des joueurs de faire
l'une fédérale 2 à tous les coups mais
je dirais que on fait avec nos moyens et
fera toujours une bonne santé financière
à la base avec une bonne ambiance entre
les joueurs partent avec le même staff
oui à une exception près on arnaud
collier qui nous rejoint florent plus
acquis qui nous suivent derrière
question coach quels seront les
objectifs du club est ce que vous avez
établi je sais pas une place au
classement à atteindre l'année prochaine
si j'aime très clairement finir en
milieu de tableau
voilà
se sortir de ce cet objectif de maintien
le plus vite possible et jouer le milieu
de tableau à la première place on
prendra ce qui arrivera mais faut être
lucide
voilà on a encore trois quatre grosses
écuries voilà qui sont qui vont être au
dessus
forcément merci à tous les deux dépassé
une sauce à tour et encore bravo pour
votre saison continuera évidemment à
suivre avec plaisir plaisir la saison
prochaine merci beaucoup à vous donner
merci nous allons maintenant rangé aller
ballon ovale pour sortir les ballons
ronds en football les ivy noir ont eux
aussi eu leur lot d'émotions trappe
aurait sûrement préféré en avoir un peu
moins les trappistes se sont sauvés dans
les dernières journées après un passage
à vide à la mi-saison et à une
finalement à la 9e place du classement
avec un bilan de 9 victoires 3 nuls et
12 défaites
il termine surtout avec la quatrième
plus mauvaise attaque du championnat les
phases offensives seront sûrement
travailler à l'intersaison par le staff
de trappes en première division de
district guyancourt terminer la saison
sur le podium du championnat en
remportant en parallèle la coupe des
yvelines mort pas longtemps dans les
trois premiers a finalement terminé son
année à la cinquième place du classement
montigny le bretonneux se sauver in
extremis avec un bilan de 4 victoires 4
matchs nuls et 14 défaites depuis début
septembre
enfin pas de miracle pour les
clayes-sous-bois mal en point toute la
saison les cliniciens n'ont remporté que
deux victoires et évolueront en deuxième
division de district l'année prochaine
handball féminin l'équipe phare de saint
quentin en yvelines l'ice montigny le
bretonneux n'a pu faire mieux qu'une 11e
place sur douze engagés dans le
championnat de nationale 2 l'objectif
initial annoncé était pourtant la montée
en fin de saison les filles de denys
choulet n'ont remporté que quatre
matches cette saison pour 2 16 défaites
avec la nouvelle réforme lésigny monta
ne descendront pas évolueront en
nationale 2 à l'année prochaine toujours
handball mais cette fois ci à chez les
garçons le samedi à 26 à mai dernier le
club de trappes a écrit l'une des plus
belles pages de son histoire les
trappistes termine la saison premiers du
championnat d'excellence départementale
est invaincu en emportant un ultime
match contre les clayes-sous-bois sur un
nouveau festival offensif le score 45 à
mais le club ne compte pas s'arrêter là
et espère encore gravir les échelons
dans les prochaines années on écoute les
réactions au micro de nicolas landry
si on arrive dans les deux premières
places ben on comptera en région donc
c'est l'objectif clairement de se garder
le groupe veut renforcer avec un ou deux
membres et puis
mais puis d'aller chercher la région
sera parti je pense à des équipes qui
ont la prétention de monter l'année
prochaine on sera pas seul et on sait
que ce sera difficile
on peut pas faire du sport en dix ans
joue à moitié on a en a encore voilà une
équipe qui se renforçaient l'année
prochaine et nous on a envie de
continuer l'aventuré
l'objectif c'est d'amener le club
d'origine on continue à parler de
handball plaisir a été l'équipe à suivre
cette année dans les yvelines promu en
nationale 3 les plis 01 failli monter
une deuxième année consécutive mais ils
se sont aussi inclinés en barrage retour
sur cette folle aventure à montage de à
xavier jana
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2010cette année de la consécration pour
le plaisir handball club après avoir
lutté pour la montée pendant six ans les
plaisirs aux accède enfin à la nationale
3 je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits c'est vraiment une
grande famille c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les doux c'est vraiment un club qui avec
lui ce moment là tous ensemble
après l'euphorie retour sur terre
plaisir se mesurer pour la première fois
une équipe de nationale 3 en coupe de
france début septembre après un match
serré les plus froids sont finalement
éliminé par le club d'ici aux tirs au
but le score 28 à 27 une défaite
formatrice pour le groupe une équipe
réellement le profil des équipes de
nationale 3 à savoir bas des joueurs
avec un petit peu tous les profils et
notamment des grands gabarits qui sont
capables d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc voila c'était très
intéressant de cette équipe
avec voilà nos qualités après quatre
mois de compétition plaisir pointe à la
deuxième place du championnat de
nationale 3 à trois longueurs du leader
saint polois les yvelines ont notamment
réalisé une série de quatre victoires
consécutives entre octobre et novembre
l'équipe a été remaniée puisque
effectivement on a perdu quelques
joueurs le fait de rappeler ces quelques
joueurs n'ont pas changé l'état d'esprit
du groupe
l'état d'esprit est toujours positif les
mecs s'entraîne sérieusement on
s'entraîne sérieusement et donc sa
deuxième place au championnat je pense
qu'elle est méritée
maintenant on sait que ça va être dur de
la garder ma nounou battre et continuer
sur cet état d'esprit qui est pour
l'instant est repproché avec cette bande
de potes à l'animé plaisir ne sourit
plus les plaisirs wa concèdent leur
troisième défaite en quatre matchs
contre l'entente pcn le score est sévère
33 à 24 plaisir redescend à la quatrième
place
les barrages s'éloigne pour plaisir et
l'équipe enregistre de nombreux blessés
le dispositif qu on a line sont pas les
dispositifs pour aligner habituellement
donc forcément on essaye de trouver des
solutions là où finalement il n'a
peut-être pas et voilà mais bon c'est
juste parce qu'on essaye de rester
compétiteurs jusqu'au bout et de se
battre avec nos armes plaisir s'accroche
dans le sprint final et enregistre deux
victoires et un match nul pour terminer
deuxième et arraché des barrages les
plaisirs à s'incline finalement contre
molsheim son terrain neutre 27 à 26 et
voient leurs espoirs de montée s'envoler
en ses projets
arrivé au match de barrage on vient
vraiment cru et sur le terrain on ya cru
parce qu'on a vraiment dominé cette
équipe de molsheim et malheureusement
sur soi le money time
ça tourne pas en notre faveur pour sa
première année en nationale 3 plaisir a
été l'équipe surprise et sera la
formation a su pour la montée la saison
prochaine nous allons ouvrir à présent
une page fitness c'est l'une des
personnalités qui aura marqué cette
saison yvelinoise caddie baradji
originaire de voisins-le-bretonneux a
été élue miss fitness france 2010 8 en
novembre dernier nous avons la chance de
la recevoir sur ce plateau pour qu'elle
nous parle de son titre bonsoir cadix
alors quelques mois plus tard avec le
recul comment analysez-vous ce titre est
ce que vous avez pu retomber un petit
peu de votre nuage complètement oui
aujourd'hui ça va ça va très très bien
d'ailleurs
ça va très bien et et j'en prends
conscience jour après jour encore
aujourd'hui je me rends compte de ce que
ça implique en fait c'est vrai qu'au
départ je me rendais pas forcément
compte que que c'était quelque chose de
tout nouveau pour moi et que ça allait
changer des choses dans ma vie je me
rendais pas forcément compter que ça va
changer justement ça a changé des choses
eh bah ça a changé que mon planning
aujourd'hui il est encore plus chargé
il était déjà pas mal à l'époque et
aujourd'hui un bain j'ai beaucoup plus
de clients
donc ça c'est un avantage gdg des
événements à couvrir et c'est à vous que
je n'avais pas forcément avant des
présences proto protocolaire entre
guillemets à gérer c'est vrai que ça je
m'y attendais pas alors sur quoi vous
avez été notée pour sevran porter ce
titre est bâclé rien ce n'est pas du
tout c'est ça qui m'a plu parce que
c'était uniquement sur les capacités
physiques c'était vraiment ce que
j'étais capable de faire moi
physiquement sur une journée entière ma
résistance musculaire mon cardio et et
et aujourd'hui j'en suis très fier alors
vous êtes une grande sportive de 30 ans
j'ai dit 29 ans précédemment mais en
fait vous avez 30 ans récemment ou
pratiquer la musculation deux à trois
fois par semaine et vous enseigner des
cours de zumba entre
montigny-le-bretonneux et voisins le
bretonneux
comment vous faites pour trouver toute
cette énergie et bien déjà
la première chose c'est que je vis de ma
passion donc forcément l'énergie c'est
pas difficile de l'avoir je me réveille
le matin je suis content d'aller au
travail je sais pourquoi j'y vais et
c'est vrai que je fais beaucoup de
choses j'ai aussi prof de paix s au
lycée
mais on fait du sport tout le temps du
sport tout le temps et du coup je peux
je ne peux que avoir l'énergie de d'y
aller tous les matins alors vous
impressionner même votre coach on écoute
je savais qu'elle allait gagner sans
aucun doute un suivi machine c'est fou
tout le temps soit j tout le temps zumba
la danse tennis crossfit fitness tout ce
que vous voulez en permanence où le
surprenant dans ce qu'il dit il a
surpris
il est surpris et surtout aujourd'hui je
suis contente parce qu'il est fier il
est fier de ce que j'ai fait et il est
fier de ce qu'on a pu faire ensemble
il m'a bien entraîné il m'a bien préparé
et quand je me suis préparé
j'y croyais pas et en plus il fallait
que j'ajoute des créneaux d'entraînement
dans le planning et on je lui dis mais
c'est pas possible
comment je vais faire pour rajouter des
créneaux d'entraînement et et il a était
flexible il s'est adapté à mon planning
hyper-chargé et ça c'était super alors
vous le disais précédemment vous
réalisez également des cours de zumba le
regard des élèves at il changé
selon alors leur regard n'a pas changé
parce que je n'ai pas changé mais par
contre elles sont fières et elle m'amène
encore plus de monde et ça c'est génial
justement on va aller les écouter
on est fier on est fiers pour être vu
par rossi est là mais sur un niveau bien
supérieur
[Musique]
vous avez une réaction
je suis très fier des filles parce que
de base elles sont un peu timides et là
de les voir au micro c'est excellent
parce qu'elles m'ont dit on va pas
parler on veut pas qu'on nous interdit
en fait elles sont tellement fiers qu
elles ont pas eu de mal à répondre à vos
questions rapidement quelle est la
prochaine étape pour vous alors déjà
life je gère mon été et puis et puis que
je prépare très bien ma prochaine saison
est ce que là on est en plein dilemme
est ce que je meurs je me remets en lice
pour la compétition et gagner remise
fitness france 2019
pourquoi pas c'est le gros suspense et
du coup préparer la saison prochaine
dans mes cours à voisin montigny au
lycée et tout ce que je fais déjà merci
qu'a dit d'être patient si au cateau bon
courage pour la suite on vous souhaite
de remporter de nouveaux titres sur sur
le fitness et pourquoi pas en 2019 verte
merci beaucoup
retour à présent sur les moments forts
qui ont fait vibrer les yvelinois sur
cette saison 2017-2018 le montage est
signée romain respini
[Musique]
ciao une réaction extraordinaire une
réaction de joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti lors de l' annonce un
parcours de golf fantastique et d'être
le capitaine de cette ryder cup est
vraiment spécial c'est une journée
incroyable avec tous ses enfants je suis
très excité à l'idée de vivre cette
ryder cup à paris
dans les yvelines grande fierté et
encore merci pour ceux qui le
soutiennent fierté un objectif terminer
on est parti pour d'autres objectifs
encore le monde c'est les gens qui ont
gravi les échelons de benjamins minimes
cadets juniors seniors donc la tronche
âge de 18 ans je pense c'est quand même
là une première au niveau national c'est
le top
on ne peut pas monter plus aujourd'hui
est donc pour nous c'est un honneur
d'une part et puis bah on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france pour le
beau département des yvelines
[Musique]
ciao
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore
lagarde
[Musique]
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif du bras de fer de comptoir
pour vos poignets soit bien droit que
votre quête tôt soit en fait je vous
ayez les poules bien en face que vous
soyez dans l'axé médian de la table
[Musique]
c'est un département qui est juste à
côté de paris
mariella et en même temps c'est la forêt
c'est la campagne bat qui a tout pour
pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement avec les années
[Musique]
c'est très productive
tous les bus étaient atteints pour viser
les causes de cécité et les partenaires
les collaborateurs l'intégration on est
très chanceux d'avoir eu cette fois le
cardon doublé je suis vraiment impatient
de vivre pleinement cette expérience de
mon premier roland garros c'est génial
c'est top quartier auront forcément on
s'y attendait pas forcément mais mais
c'est vraiment un super cadeau on va
essayer de se concentrer à 100% pour en
tirer le meilleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
victoire un peu logique et papa de
surprise pour moi psychologiquement et
physiquement je pense qu'on est un peu
mieux que maurepas sur cette deuxième
partie de saison donc pas surpris disons
qu'on a bien préparé notre match depuis
un moment et puis on les aurait été
super motivé voulait absolument la
gagner
[Musique]
c'est une tradition c'est l'histoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'histoire de cette colline ce site il
était à l'abandon et à que vraiment nous
notre club qui utilise aussi de akon
d'elancourt et quand on pense qu'on a eu
à voir les jeux olympiques je pense que
on a mis une petite pierre à l'édifice
pour que les jeux soient ici quoi
[Musique]
toujours motivé à quelques jours du
départ du tour de france voilà c'est
notre départ du championnat de france
est toujours une course spéciale donc je
suis content d'être ici pas c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de française comme
molinari à wentworth quand vous êtes si
proche vous voulez vraiment cette
victoire
mais c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir aujourd'hui et on referme ce
numéro par deux rendez-vous qu'il nous
faudra pas manquer en septembre dans les
yvelines en golf la ryder cup 2018 sera
organisé du 28 au 30 septembre golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
bien jean robin affronteront les
meilleurs joueurs américains pendant
trois jours sur les greens les 60000
spectateurs quotidiens pourront
notamment voir tiger woods sont encore
rory mcilroy à l'oeuvre au total plus de
750 millions de téléspectateurs
devraient regarder la compétition à la
télévision
enfin en baseball et cougar de montigny
le bretonneux vise le titre cette saison
dans le championnat de première division
est une place en coupe d'europe et c'est
plutôt bien parti pour lésiner montagne
sont pour l'instant classé dans le top 4
français
un résultat qui leur permettra d'accéder
aux playoffs qui se dérouleront à partir
de la mi septembre mais les cougars vont
devoir bien géré la pause estivale on
écoute on écoute avec son couteau
joueurs de l'équipe au micro de nicolas
maury c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
justement de gérer la trêve estivale
on a on va reprendre 15 jours avant et
se prépare au mieux mais c'est jamais
facile quoi a pas trop le choix
c'est la fin de cette fille du sport
spécialité merci de l'avoir subi on se
retrouve en septembre prochain pour de
nouvelles aventures sportives très bel
été sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]